Speaker 1: OK, let's hear from some of you
in the audience via The David Pakman Show
discord, which you can find at David Pakman
dot com slash discord, we use discord instead
of a so-called real phone number. Now, I feel
that the audio quality has improved. I feel
substantively, arguably, things have also
improved. OK, let's start today with Azana
from Atlanta, Georgia. Azana, you were on
the air.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Hello, Michael. Pleasure.
I wanted to ask you, in light of the Derek
Shervin verdict. Yes. Do you think that the
conversations that are being had around police
brutality, systemic racism, more broadly are
doing more harm or damage to the left in terms
of gaining public support and getting the
people we want elected?
Speaker 1: I don't think that they're doing
more harm than good, but I question whether
they're always doing that much good. Does
that make sense?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I kind of think you can elaborate
a little. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I mean, I think that sometimes
the conversation on the left around police
brutality and around race is disproportionate
to the degree to which something is a problem
in the real world. So, like as an example,
I'm not a class reductionist, so class reductionism
would be any problem that seems to be about
race or ethnicity or religion, really. It's
actually about class. And if you deal with
inequality in class, the problem gets resolved.
That's class reductionism. I'm not a class
reductionist. And so but but given that there
are times when, as an example, when you look
at the number of of of black Americans killed
by police in the year and you look at the
amount of conversation about it versus the
degree to which economic factors are a huge
role player in poverty and therefore in education
and therefore in being in neighborhoods where
there is more crime and where police are paying
more attention, rightly or wrongly. Right.
I mean, that's a that's a whole other debate.
Sometimes it feels as though as though the
conversation has gotten a little bit out of
sync with the proportion to which these different
things are problems. And of course, these
are all problems. But I would like to see
the conversation maybe a little more fine
tuned like here. Let me give you one other
really specific example. It's become very
popular now for police departments and corporations
to announce in response to what's going on,
we will be sending our officers or our employees
to anti bias trainings to learn about implicit
bias. Is there evidence that that actually
reduces the types of incidents that are problematic?
I've looked for it and I can't find it. So
I worry that it's more of like a PR thing
than it is actually dealing with the problem.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I think I definitely think
there is sort of a a certain degree of virtue
signaling that's going on, and I don't think
it's always in bad faith. I think a lot of
the time it is in good faith. I agree. But
I'm the overall thing that I'm thinking of.
This is just more broadly, I'm just wondering
if this is some of the reasons why, like Trump
had so much support,
Speaker 3: if we're going too far with some
of these issues, and especially now, because
I genuinely thought January six was going
to be
Speaker 2: like the death of the Republican
Party, it never affects that. Yeah, yeah.
But the fact that, like Trump did an interview
the other night on Hannity and that they seem
to still have a lot of energy on their side,
I'm wondering if it's coming back to these
type of issues that are the reasons for that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't I don't I'm not ready
to say that it is, you know, I've expressed
the concerns I have, but I wouldn't be ready
to make such a sweeping statement.
Speaker 2: OK. All right,
Speaker 1: Mike Boettcher, thank you so much
for the call, very much appreciate it. Always
very, very important issue. And one I think
that must be dealt with in a realistic way.
You know, we shouldn't pretend things are
different. If something is a problem, we should
deal with the problem rather than just insisting
it's not a problem. Let's go next to Stephanie.
I think it's from Richmond. Is that Stephanie
from Richmond, Virginia?
Speaker 2: No, hi. It's Stephanie from Richardson,
Texas.
Speaker 1: Oh, sorry. Ray was cut off. Richardson,
Texas. Welcome, Stephanie.
Speaker 2: Hi, how are you? I'm doing well,
actually. I wasn't really prepared. I just
kept listening today, but I actually had to
quit. And I did start think about the question
I wanted to ask about some time in Texas.
We have a lot of issues, as you may know.
OK, say more about that. Yeah, go ahead.
Speaker 1: So, no, I was going to say tell
me more about the issues. Yeah, well,
Speaker 2: where do I start? So it's like
obviously I watched your clip the other day
about how Matthew, we say kind of sort of
in Texas, but Matthew McConaughey has thrown
his hat in the ring, which I don't know if
he would even be a decent candidate, but it
is evident of how people are starting. Our
climate is changing, hopefully. And I'm thinking
like personally, I wanted to get more active
and like not I don't know, I don't want to
say, but like being more proactive in raising
awareness. And so I wouldn't really know how
to start with all that. Since you seem pretty
educated on the subject of educating people.
I know once the government government races
candidacy starts and people start getting
out there, I'm hoping that he decides to run
again and it'll be interested. Know, I'm just
hoping, like I would like some advice or tips
that you could offer as far as being someone
I'm not necessarily shy for, say, but I'm
not super proactive like any suggestions you
can throw out there about like being someone
who. I know that.
Speaker 1: Oh, boy, Stephanie, we just lost
we just lost it for a second, we just lost
you there, Stephanie. But here's here's the
thing. The great thing about being a progressive
in Texas is there are so many opportunities
to get involved to try to unseat a right wing
nut. So whether it's city councils, mayors
races, a gubernatorial race, whatever, there's
no shortage of opportunities and you can really
make an impact. Whereas, you know, the truth
is you can participate in local races anywhere.
But sometimes it's less interesting to look
at replacing, you know, a left wing Democrat
with a five percent more left wing Democrat.
It's like, you know, OK, I mean, it's a move
to the left, but sometimes it's less rewarding.
There are so many opportunities in Texas that
you could really get involved in that. And,
you know, if you don't want to be knocking
on doors or calling people, because that's
not your personality, there's other things
that can be done. You can contact people via
text message. There's so many campaigns to
get involved in.
Speaker 2: Right. And that's what I think
I'm leaning towards because I've obviously
become more politically aware over the last
few years. And it's something that I as having
a teenage daughter, there's things that are
going to start impact her life. So I want
to get involved and be a little bit more of
a game changer because we like that. We have
a lot of problems. We need to fix something
because I don't think I can fix them all that.
I'm sad because Texas really is a great state,
but we're getting such a bad reputation. That
makes me very sad.
Speaker 1: What Richardson, Texas, is that
in a more blue or red area, I don't I'm not
familiar with. I think that's pretty rad.
Speaker 2: We're we're our work of north of
Dallas. But, yeah, as you know, Dallas is
pretty blue and so is Austin, Houston and
things like that. But some of the suburbs
are definitely a little bit more red. But
I think that my area might be a little bit
more purple. I'm hoping that, you know, it's
going to be as changing as we have a pretty
diverse community here where I live. So it's
like hopefully things are going to start to
change.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, plenty of opportunities
to get involved stuff and to keep us posted.
Speaker 2: Thanks. You have a great day.
Speaker 1: All right. Stephanie from Texas,
great to hear from her. Why don't we go next
to. Oh, I don't know. Let's go to Rob from
East Hampton. How about. Hello, hello, you're
on the air.
Speaker 4: Oh, this is exciting. So I guess
I have two questions, but I'll start with
the first one. So the first one I would ask
is what does one position you used to hold
but you sort of changed your mind on now?
Speaker 1: One position I used to hold, but
I've changed my mind on that. I mean, a lot
of economic stuff where, you know, my initial
introduction to economics in high school and
early in college was just straight neoclassical
economics. And now that I've, you know, studied
everything from behavioral economics to Marxian
economics and everything in between, I have
a much more I would call it real world view
rather than the theoretical neoclassical view.
Speaker 4: OK, interesting, I ask that because
I used to like I was a big proponent for Medicare
for all. OK, and then after last year, you
know, I kind of see, OK, you know, the majority
of the population doesn't want Medicare for
all. So I sort of like, you know, change my
views or I guess I compromise more, I would
say.
Speaker 1: Now, hold on a second. That's interesting.
What you're not saying. You changed your view
on Medicare for all because you found out
something about it that you didn't like. It
sounds like you're saying you changed your
view because other people don't like it
Speaker 4: just in terms of electability.
It's not it's realistically, I feel like it's
not going to happen just because not that
many people, people support Medicare for all.
But when it comes to sort of like the intricate
details, that's where you kind of see, like,
support falling off.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you're not wrong. And I've
talked about that data from the Kaiser Family
Foundation before, which is not part of the
firm Kaiser Permanente. My view on this has
been I want to get to universal coverage with
affordability and a reasonable standard of
care. And in order to do that, there's a lot
of different ways that you can approach it.
Different countries have approached it in
different ways. I'm not married to Medicare
for all, and I have a long segment about other
ways it could be arranged. As long as we get
to the right, as long as we get to the finish
line, I'm open to different ways of running
a race.
Speaker 4: Definitely, definitely agree there.
I just have a really strong bias because I
strongly dislike insurance companies, so I
would just prefer a Medicare for all system.
But again, electability wise, it is the most
popular thing. The second question I had kind
of having a difficulty wording it, but given
Biden's handling of the situation at the border,
do you think this sort of I would say his
lack of outreach to the Hispanic community
during the 2012 election, do you think this
can kind of impact how, you know, midterms
so in 2022?
Speaker 1: I don't think that will impact
the midterms. Is Joe Biden's outreach or lack
of outreach to the Latino community? I think
that what will impact the 2010 midterms are
is how does the Biden administration react
to right wing media and Republican elected
officials successfully making immigration
a much bigger issue than it was six months
ago. We just looked at polling which showed
that in June of twenty twenty twenty eight
percent of Americans believed that illegal
immigration was a big issue last month. Forty
eight percent of Americans believed illegal
immigration was a big issue. This is a win
for Republicans because they know Trump failed
on covid and Biden has high approval on it.
They know Trump failed to jumpstart vaccination
and Joe Biden has a really high approval on
it. The the one point nine trillion stimulus
that Biden did has really high approval. So
what Republicans are doing is saying, let's
come up with something to shift attention
to. They've chosen immigration and it's working.
So now that half the country says it's a serious
issue, the question is, how does Biden deal
with it? I don't think it's outreach to Latino
voters. I think it's what does the perception
become over how Joe Biden is handling the
issue? And we don't know yet what it will
be because we still have a while until the
2022 midterms.
Speaker 4: OK, well, thank you so much for
taking my questions.
Speaker 1: All right, my pleasure. Rob, from
is it is it East Hampton, New York or Massachusetts?
Massachusetts. Wow. OK, what what's your top
restaurant in East Hampton right now?
Speaker 4: I'm not going to lie, Keysborough.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, yeah, I can't go wrong
with. Yep. All right, good. OK, thanks for
the call, Rob. Very, very good. Let's take
a very quick break. But if you're holding,
don't hang up because we're taking more calls
momentarily. Quick break and right back after
this.